kyle cooper is a senior with a 3.8 grade
point average his declared major is
accounting and he intends to pursue a
career as a public or corporate
accountant at Hillsdale he plays on the
charger basketball team and assists with
the Hillsdale County Career access
planning project kyle is the second of
three children his younger sibling is a
university sophomore and his older
sibling is a University graduate the
family lives in northville michigan his
father is a real estate manager for ITC
holdings and his mother is self-employed
hello class of 2019 and welcome to
Hillsdale College as dr. Whalen
introduced I am Kyle Cooper I'm a member
of the men's basketball team and I'll be
entering my second year as a team
captain I am also an accounting major
which I understand sometimes comes with
a connotation that I may be a boring
person and I know it's been a long day
so I'll do my best to not be too boring
first of all I would like to acknowledge
what an honor it is to be speaking to
all of you today as you begin your
college careers as I thought about what
to say to all of you as well as your
parents I began to think about my own
time as an incoming freshman I received
a lot of advice from a lot of different
people learn to manage your time try not
to procrastinate build relationships
with your professors and administrators
and so much more that I'm sure a lot of
you have already heard you should know
that all that advice is more true than
you may even realize at this time though
it is not always easy to put into
practice as evidenced by the fact that I
still struggle with procrastination
because if we're being honest sometimes
watching the football game is more
attractive than writing a paper but
again it is good advice and I promise
the more disciplined you become the
better off you will be in your time at
college
by taking responsibility for your
actions and your grades they might be
difficult but it's not always the
professor's fault authority over your
own decisions and more importantly
accountability for the results of those
decisions the more likely you are to
experience success and that's what a lot
of advice tends to be focused on isn't
it how to get good grades earn a high
GPA build a good resume for your career
after college the quote-unquote success
I don't mean to take away from success
in the classroom at college because it
is a fundamental part of helping to open
some doors after school but speaking
from my own experience as a freshman I
remember feeling that the advice i was
given began to turn college into this
big game excuse the athletic reference a
contest where the winners leave happy
and the losers regretful please do not
ever let college or your life for that
matter turn into that people look at a
high school graduation class as you were
a few months ago or a group of incoming
college freshman as you are today and
it's easy for them to say you are the
future you are the next generation of
doctors lawyers politicians and so on
now I to believe that this freshman
class as well as all classes from
Hillsdale College will have an impact on
our country's future but today I'm
encouraging each of you not to look past
the steps that lead to that point but
rather to focus your attention on each
individual step waking up each day with
the determination to make that single
day great can have a profound impact on
your time here mistakes are always the
best learning material so I'd like to
offer you one of mine as a teaching
point see as a freshman when I was in
your
news I allowed myself to go through the
motions I woke up I went to class
practice dinner homework and studying
and back to bed day after day I did this
and it was that discipline that allowed
me to have some success here but I found
myself at the end of my freshman year
not having truly enjoyed college very
much I reflect on that experience and
realized that while I was disciplined
and that is a very important trait for
success I had become stagnant and that's
something that I wish to help all of you
avoid there's no staying the same you're
either improving or falling behind it's
a quote that I've heard a lot in sports
but it easily translates into all walks
of life use college to push your
boundaries learn to make time in one day
to go to class to get your homework done
participate in a grouper club call your
parents again this is you learning from
my mistakes and even hang out with your
friends in the dorm at night we are at a
very small college as I'm sure all of
you know allow the people here to become
a second family it's so easy to go
through today and make acquaintances
with the people you see wave hello as
you pass by smile it's a lot harder to
sit down or stand with someone and
expose yourself and have a true
conversation and make true friendships
but I promise you relationships are more
important in this life than any grade
you will receive in your four or five
years here carry yourself in a way that
you can be proud of every day focus on
all those little things that make each
day special really get to know the
people here and trust me there's a lot
of great ones and I promise you will
enjoy your college experience
congratulations on beginning a new stage
in life
and welcome to Hillsdale College